yes as I said after our top 10 best list
does come a top 10 worst list I like my
top 10 best list these are my personal
picks I'm not saying these are the 10
movies that you should hate I'm saying
these are the 10 movies that I saw this
year that I personally just hated for
one reason or another and the funny
thing is there are some terrible movies
that came out that won't be on this list
because I didn't see him 2012 was the
year that I took a little bit back for
myself piranhas three double D didn't
come out in my local movie theater so I
was like I'm not gonna go search the
movie out so I could watch it I'm better
than that I deserve better then when I
was doing my Christmas shopping and I
found piranha 3 double D there for like
five bucks on DVD and I was like I could
buy it but if I spend five bucks on this
movie and I don't put five bucks in the
little Santa Clause ringing the bell
kettle thing I'll be a dick I'll be an
[ __ ] and I just the five bucks could
be better spent anywhere else that's
what I'm saying so there were a couple
movies that are terrible that are not on
this list it's just cuz I didn't see
them because I chose not to
however all the movies I did see here
they are number 10 as my top 10 best
list started off with an animation top
10 worst is also gonna start off with an
animation Ice Age 4 continental drift
yeah whenever there's a fourth
installment of a movie you're like okay
is this gonna be forced not only is it
gonna be forced but it's gonna have
annoying characters a villain that's
totally missed cast yeah this movie
never happened the world would not be
any worse for the where was Liam Neeson
a badass and taken yes he was was he a
badass and taken to believe did have his
daughter throw corn aids off of a roof
that happened in the movie moments like
that or why this is number nine people
who saw this movie got their money taken
I guess that's something no good hey
coming in at number eight is the
concluding chapter to the Twilight Saga
the Twilight Saga Breaking Dawn Part two
I'm sure people would think this would
be higher up on the list but it's not I
didn't give this movie a dog [ __ ] rating
because I felt they really did try given
the content that being said a cool
little throw down at the end of the
movie is just not enough you look at the
movie the premise the dialogue between
the characters that you don't care about
you're like yeah this is probably going
to make my top 10 worst list somewhere
as bad as its predecessors no good
enough to miss out on my top 10 worst
list of the year not in his unit
number seven I do have mixed thoughts
about the Three Stooges movie because I
was a big Three Stooges fan growing up I
almost challenge you to see The Three
Stooges movie as I see it right close
your eyes and imagine the three main
characters are not the Three Stooges
there's three other characters who comes
to mind Adam Sandler Rob Schneider and
someone else who could be in an Adam
Sandler movie I love the old Three
Stooges shorts they're funny they work
for what they are but this movie is just
three people impersonating the three
stooges with a premise and a script that
could have been done by Adam Sandler
number six okay I thought underworld was
over now I know it should have been 2012
had some moments of great movies other
moments it was filled with fourth
installments that were completely forced
Underworld Awakening is one of those
movies and if it didn't look like a
bunch of flashy [ __ ] for the sake of
making a movie it looked like a bunch of
really over exaggerated [ __ ] for the
sake of making a video game I have to
believe if you're an underworld fan you
you still don't like the movie number
five how awkward can mother and son get
this awkward the guilt trip this is one
of those movies the more you think about
it the more you're like nope that movie
just infuriates me it's just
uncomfortable this mother-son duo which
is one of those situations where you're
like can this family reunion ends so I
don't feel so uncomfortable watching you
two I would rather watch The Girl with
the Dragon Tattoo ass rape scene with my
mom sitting right next to me to watch
this uncomfortable mother-son duo
again number four every installment of
this movie franchise I hate but every
one of them I go into going maybe this
is the one where they'll actually make
it good Resident Evil retribution taught
me nope that's just hoping against hope
Resident Evil retribution was like
Transformers Revenge of the Fallen a
bunch of flashy [ __ ] noise was thrown on
the screen for the sake of making action
sequences with no real point whatsoever
just like now we're just gonna do it and
and have it done
no first alright we're getting down to
the wire these are the three movies
where I was like I could have completely
done without that number three on the
list shows us that not only did 2012
have really forced 4th installment of
franchises some really forced sequels
also and that's Ghost Rider spirit of
vengeance this movie had a couple of
cool ish scenes but in the end you're
like why did that happen I didn't like
it because I was sober while watching it
don't drop acid while watching movies
otherwise we'll keep getting movies like
this number true coming in at number two
you ever see those movies where you're
like this was meant to come out on
Netflix but it had a couple of big
actors in it so it came out theatrically
yeah cold light of day that's that movie
in my review I professed that Bruce
Willis and Henry Cavill were the only
reason PSA's came out in theaters then I
was at the store and I saw a
straight-to-dvd Bruce Willis movie I was
like well clearly it wasn't him
Cavill I hope you kill it as Superman
otherwise I'm going to remember you for
this please don't make me do that
nobo 1 and here it is this is the movie
that infuriated me the most bored me the
most made me roll my eyes the most shake
my head the most and just mentally check
out of the movie theater keeping with
the cliche that video game movies are
terrible is Silent Hill revelation I
actually halfway got out of my seat
halfway through this movie and I was
like no I'm gonna stick this out this
movie had nothing interesting I had some
cool visuals but that is literally it I
really can't add anything I didn't
already say in my review of this movie
but as I said before this movie was made
by set designers who were like hey this
would be really cool in a movie let's
put them in a movie in a sequence that
doesn't make any sense because we're not
writers or directors Silent Hill
revelation reminds me that there's never
going to be a really good video game
based movie out there that genre those
franchises are stuck in this cinematic
vortex of just a downward spiral of doom
wreck-it Ralph is different it's not a
movie based off of a video game it's an
adventure animation that uses an arcade
video game multiverses its playground as
for video game based movies no I suppose
I wouldn't hate the movie so much if the
acting was good but when Sean Bean is
terrible in a movie the world didn't end
in 2012 but seeing Sean Bean so terrible
my heart did break Silent Hill
revelation you topped the list as the
worst of the worst of 2012 my friend so
that is my list of the top 10 worst
movies that I personally saw in 2012 so
now like before it's up to you guys what
are your top 10 worst movies of 2012
comment below let me know or make a
video response and put that as a
response to this [ __ ] that's how we roll
here and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more